que coisa é essa
faz com que estrelas da música como
madonna e na telegraph mantras em santo
e japonês que faz com que pilotos de
fórmula 1
larguem tudo e vou morar no campo que
faz com que um padre se torne um
astrônomo e cosmólogo eo médico
professor se torne monge zen budista
literalmente não sei até porque eu não
sei como é que eu vim parar aqui pois é
claramente em vários momentos da nossa
vida a gente seja aquelas perguntas
essenciais
quem sou eu o que a gente tem que fazer
nesse intervalo entre vida e morte
chamado viva o que me faz levantar da
cama todos os dias pela manhã o que
acontece depois que a gente morre e isso
está ligado diretamente ao conceito de
espiritualidade ou seja a busca de
respostas sobre coisas da vida sobre o
sentido da vida ea relação com o
transcendente que é aquilo que está
realmente além de nós então gente para
poder explicar como a espiritualidade
ela é o fim uma ferramenta de conexão
interpessoal
eu peço licença e não foi à toa que eu
subi com uma xícara de café
peço licença porque é eu adoro café
principalmente e há 20 anos eu não
gostava de café
a agente populado científico né as
pesquisas falam que 90% das pessoas
deste país tomou café professores alunos
e trabalhadores das mais diversas áreas
cientistas só da gente olhar as imagens
do café a gente consegue imaginar o
cheiro
só gente falar a palavra fé a gente
consegue ter idéia do cheiro
o que acontece é que também se estuda
efeitos benéficos do café café e melhora
a função de eliminar os pensamentos ele
nos ajuda a pensar
também se estuda efeitos maléficos do
café estudar o efeito como havia como
insônia e falo do até café causa quente
em algumas situações
e após estudar a dose letal de cafeína
então por isso há 20 anos quando era
estudante de medicina lá pelo segundo
ano antes de sair da casa de um pastor
evangélico e de uma dona de casa
patológica praticante para tentar me
aventurar em pelo menos 45 vivências
espirituais diferentes até o presente
momento eu estava café e odiava café
só que eu quero falar de algo mais sutil
porque isso é apenas um detalhe
cientificismo não é querer explicar a
realidade que a gente vive com relações
de causalidade tem algo mais útil quando
a gente fala do café tem um grande café
então pra gente pensar no grande o café
para poder ter tido café
a gente teve que ter tido o grão teve
que ter tido a água da chuva
uma pessoa que fez perguntas essenciais
sobre a vida assim como eu me fiz como
me faço até hoje que plantou café
outro grupo de pessoas que fizeram
perguntas essenciais sobre a vida que
colheram café
outro grupo que achou ponto de torra do
café
outro grupo que morreu café mas um grupo
de pessoas que fez perguntas sobre a
vida e não sabe muitas vezes que estavam
fazendo assim como eu não sei que estou
fazendo aqui elas controlar a qualidade
do café
outro grupo em só com o café outro grupo
voltou transportou alguém comprou trouxe
e teve uma pessoa que me alcançou o café
ou seja a a esse café existir teve que
tirar chuva teve que tímido sol e ter
tido solo e um conjunto de pessoas que
fizeram várias perguntas até chegar o
presente momento
ou seja o grande com fé assim como nós
mesmos somos o conjunto de causas e
condições até o presente momento
em julgamentos em categorias as coisas
acontecem relação assim pra o café ele
ter sido café tiveram que ocorrer todas
essas cadeias de sucessão de
acontecimentos que ficar bem visível de
pessoas até que eu nem conheço até o
café ter chegado aqui
a grande questão é que a gente acaba
muitas vezes atropelando alguns aspectos
da nossa vida quando a gente pensa em
causa de condições ea gente acaba
gerando uma coisa chamada meta emoção
ou seja a gente gera emoção a partir de
emoção
a gente fica que angustia quando vê
alguém chorando cirurgia com o novo
alguém tossindo e aí começa às vezes a
emitir julgamento
aquela moça lá entediado sai do celular
aquele lá para domingo no meu não faz
isso então a gente começa a criar
emoções a partir de emoções ea gente
acaba colocando a emoção em cima de
emoção e acaba querendo a partir da
minha emoção jogar as emoções do outro
ea gente faz uma coisa de menos que é
essencialmente ligado à espiritualidade
chamado nessa condição que apenas
observar os pensamentos afere para
chegar aqui tem uma cadeia de
acontecimentos tudo bem tiveram pessoas
que fizeram várias perguntas sobre a
vida
mas o grande café e se ele não ficou com
a consciência se tal ele por sua
história tá bom tá ruim
o tal frio tá quente quem acaba fazendo
isso a gente a gente aprende acaba no
fim
a novicer vá os pensamentos sendo assim
gente ficar fé e água café e ele precisa
de sol e água e nós precisamos de sol e
água fresca à conclusão que nós somos
plantinhas emoções complicadas
sendo assim ciência e espiritualidade
elas não se opõe
elas não estão em pólos opostos de
ninguém até porque a gente a gente pegar
por exemplo a teoria do big ben aquela
super explosão que criou o universo ela
estava inscrita há milhares de anos
uma cosmogonia da religião hinduísta e
ela foi criada e descrita por um padre
chamado george eduardo demetri padre
católico que estudou escreveu ele é o
padre astrônomo e cosmólogo do início da
nossa conversa e ele disse a vida
inteira no início do século passado que
a sua fé e as suas pesquisas não se
sobrepunham uma alta espiritualidade
como ferramenta de conexão ela tem
varela parte de vários pressupostos a
simples mesmo primeira coisa é tipo
cartões de banco
ela é direta pessoal e intransferível
a jornada pela qual eu passei por quatro
cinco religiões até chegar no budismo
talvez encontrar como aquilo que que
sentido é direto é individual é único é
intuitivo ou seja a gente vai
literalmente aprendendo a ler sinais ao
longo da vida a gente observa as quatro
estações estão aí tem dias que chove
entendia que fazem sol ea gente tem que
aprender a observar isso e aprender a
fluir com isso a afirmação e sentido de
vida espiritualidade não necessariamente
têm carregado com o sistema de crenças
no mesmo a gente só coloca seres divinos
nu em cena se a gente quiser
o mais importante é a gente entender
aquilo que me afirma m faz sentido de
vida precisa de ferramentas específicas
uma delas eu gosto de chamar que a
humildade cultural que isso é um
processo de uma vida inteira de
auto-reflexão autocrítica e avaliação
das relações desiguais que existe no
mundo nós somos diferentes
quem sai do lugar do dizer ah eu sei que
sente uma mulher por exemplo para dizer
eu não sei eu não faço a menor ideia a
ideia vamos construir isso juntos ea
humildade cultural ela permitia
entendendo a diversidade cultural que
existe no mundo ela me permite viver uma
coexistência pacífica e isso é
extremamente espiritual não preciso
disso
as religiões livros sagrados para isso
eu ainda tenho uma segunda ferramenta
que a escuta compassiva a gente é o
terrado por informações
fala pessoal das comunicações falam que
a gente chega absorver 1 trilhão de
informações por dia redes sociais música
ao dó informações em sala de aula
mas o que acaba acontecendo é que
dificilmente a gente pára escuta porque
o que acontece muitas vezes quando a
gente pára e se diz que estava com ela
dita escuta ativa a gente tá ouvindo mas
a partir de uma coisa um eu duvido que
eu não concordo com quem está falando ea
escuta passiva
ela é uma ferramenta onde o deixe de
lado as minhas impressões as minhas
projeções e eu escuto sem deixar de lado
a com paixão e compaixão aqui leia se
como empatia em movimento é algo que vai
além apenas dar um tapinha nas costas e
falar eu te entendo na verdade é que
mais eu posso fazer por ti e é sem as
minhas preces posições porque a gente
acaba fazendo muitas vezes é que a gente
projeta demais analisa demais sobre
utiliza de mais ou menos a mente e tem
paciência de menos alguém poderia ter
perguntado por que essa conversa não foi
sobre já eu não gosto de café também eu
há 20 anos odiava café e hoje em dia eu
adoro café
a gente pode falar sobre está também
existe um monge vietnamita maravilhoso
chamado que não é que ele fala algumas
coisas sobre chá
ele fala é uma das reflexões dele fala
aqui por exemplo quando o circo chá tudo
objeto da minha com atenção e
concentração estão no ato de servir o
chá quando tomo chá minha mente está no
passado no futuro nem estar com os meus
projetos para simplesmente ali um site
não é algo muito distante o nirvana a
gente fala que buda o consolo quando
sentou a iluminação não é algo que para
o outro lado do arco íris ele não viu um
pote de ouro ele simplesmente tem que
despertar e ele me passou
algumas coisas na vida fazem sentido
para mim é mais ou menos a busca que eu
tenho de novo continuou não fazem a
menor idéia do que eu estou fazendo aqui
então o que acontece é que o texto não
falava que dentre outras coisas
ontem teve uma nuvem e hoje tivemos um
chá isso ele chama de em terceiro
interfere a gente fala que é as coisas
não existem por si só as coisas elas
existem
eu poderia dizer que um grão de café
continua todo o universo porque tem
coisa que tem dna no café como tem dna e
nós mas eu sou um pouquinho além de um
pouco mais audacioso e trazer um
conceito que chamo de inter viver a
gente não só inter é sair desse lugar do
hewson ea gente inter vive no meu caso
eu sou médico de família
eu sou professor e os o monge zen
budista
eles inter vive em mim mas isso também
valem porque o inter viver é qual é são
as marcas de impressões que o deixam as
pessoas e que marca as impressões que as
pessoas deixam em mim quando passa no
corredor e emitam um sorriso mt um
simples bom dia isso é inter viver entre
viver a gente a a acaba exatamente
cruzando as nossas vidas de maneira que
pai e mãe são pai e mãe porque existem
filhos e disse que ela foi professores
são professores porque tem os alunos
então a gente é mais do que apenas se a
gente vive ea gente não só com vive
agente intervir a gente causa impressões
nas pessoas as pessoas nos deixa
impressões com sorrisos até que as
pensões sociais
o grande desafio talvez seja assim como
um grande café e um pouco mais neutro e
não a entrar em um sofrimento ou queria
fazer muita emoção em cima disso a gente
por fim a não se preocupem caso a gente
não acha o manual de instruções
coisa chamada vida porque a vida ela não
cabe me a vida não cabe no currículo o
que eu queria dizer a vocês sobre
espiritualidade conexões é tomamos um
café ou chá ou qualquer outra bebida e
em breve vamos uns com os outros
olho no olho e com toda a empresa de ser
poder fazer escutas com passivas mais do
que ouvi falar e discorda de vocês mais
do que eu sei o que você sente
na verdade lugar do não saber é muito
maravilhoso por isso que existem alunos
em escolas e universidades pessoas que
nos ouvir e que a gente possa ouvir que
a gente possa então entre viver mais
eu sou imensamente grato a vocês por
inter e vivemos muito obrigado